I don't think I've ever been as nervous
to film a video as as I am now so
something happened I think you all know
by now
PewDiePie freaking mentioned the channel
didn't he at like PewDiePie had a little
shout out competition thing a while back
no it's just like wouldn't it be cool
just you do it would be cool but there's
no way that I'm going to win so let's
just put my channel down and see what
happens and it happens it happens it it
happens on that weekend why I go to
Cambridge to give a talk about the
random I crater technologist exhibition
that's happening because I am making an
interactive video with a Razzie pi it's
all that's pretty crazy tell you
something I've given talks and features
might slow down
no one is understanding you I have had
the most amazing amazing weekend I just
can't believe it I'm still reeling from
just the excitement of it all
I go to Cambridge to give a speech about
an exhibition where a product that I
have been working on for a while will be
exhibited and on the way to Cambridge
PewDiePie mentions the channel he has
mentioned
YAG man acts he's mentioned us how
amazing is that
I was already excited but then I we got
more excited and then I cried a little
on the train of course who wouldn't you
have to you have to cry there's too many
things going on we hold it inside to go
crazy you internal combusting you're
probably not gonna watch this but thank
you so much I cannot believe that he has
watched this channel he's checked out
the channel he's looked at the videos
and he likes what we're doing because
I've always worried that I do too many
different things
PewDiePie said he liked this channel
because it's unique it's different it
does different things and that is the
biggest compliment it is just the hugest
because that's exactly what we're trying
to do here on Yacktman X we are not one
thing or another we are just a
passionate group of people who have
similar interests
rooo you know we're a bit nerdy I'm a
techie we like our games and we get
super enthusiastic about topics and I
just want to kind of bring all that
together and just do a bunch of
different things to really inspire you
guys and make you happy just brighten
your day a bit that is my ultimate girl
girl or girl that is my ultimate goal
now thanks to PewDiePie there are more
people that have discovered the channel
and they're enjoying it and finding
happiness from it and freak that's
awesome thank you to everyone who
checked out the channel from his video
and left a comment or even if you
checked it out and you didn't like it
thank you for checking it out I just I
I'm baffled and I'm so happy that you
guys have come here I'm so happy that a
lot of you are giving such amazing
feedback and you actually really like
the content what content is this a lot
of you might be a little bit confused
because YAG Mannix is slightly different
I guess which is why we once this is
good this is good basically I just gotta
make videos of whatever interests me
however I really like to get you guys as
involved as I possibly can which is why
I do quite enjoy a good live stream you
might have noticed my last few videos
was very livestream orientated it's
strange you you came in with my last in
my previous videos that's always kind of
experimenting more with live-streaming
yeah I did a huge Valentine's Day
livestream for everyone to feel
connected and together and oh my gosh so
cheese I like to think that YouTube is
about the community it's about people
being able to connect with one another
I'm a screen unfortunately I am just
pixels on a screen I am NOT in real-time
but I want you to know that if you
comment I will see it and I do try to
respond to comments and this is what
blew my mind because I was trying to
respond to comments and I end
I can't miss so many so this is why I'm
making this and this is why I'm pretty
excited because I've I've never read
through so many comments before and yeah
this is what happens that you should see
this you should see me in my manic manic
happy state you did this this is your
fault this is your fault
welcome you quick summary I love to play
games sing get scared
I love spooky things I don't know why I
like to talk about topics that I'm
interested about I like to travel I like
to find out things about people Rick
this just blows the stuff on this
channel I don't think you'll ever get
bored you might know another thing that
I like is technology and that's the
other awesome part to the freakin
awesome weekend that I have just got
back from I was at ratify PI party razza
PI's a tangled computer thing I'm a
little bit into tech I'm more into
software development but I'm not gonna
believe it all that and basically I've
been making an interactive video project
and it's gonna be exhibited on the 23rd
of April at Rossi PI headquarters and I
went on stage and told everyone about
that are pretty much been running off a
trend line for for this whole weekend I
have just been waiting to get back home
and talk to you on the camper and just
say thank you thank you
really oh bloody oh it's real when the
pewdiepie a shout out happened I was
looking at all of your comments I'm so
overwhelmed by how many people are so
happy for me and we're congratulating me
it's just so lovely to know that you
share in the joy that comes with the
growth of this channel it's not just me
it's it's us I just want you to know
exactly how I feel because it's awesome
and if you're gonna stick around you
should do the real me and this this is
that if you don't like cheese do not
subscribe to
channel serious I try not to be too
cheesy but I know we're very cheesy and
emotional breath I just it doesn't feel
real 6,000 and now it's now it's 16,000
is 10,000 of you look out for live
streams look out for Let's Plays look
out for songs
look out for more videos cuz they'll be
coming well I love you dare evening why
are we here
am i homeless hello no don't go